let's introduce a bit of notation to
talk about this because we've already
got tons of notation
to talk about derivatives right but we
don't have any to talk about
primitives right so usually we would say
if you've got some function f of x okay
and if you were to differentiate it say
take the derivative okay what's our
standard way what's our notation
for that f dash x right
okay but what if you know
we don't we don't want to start from
here then differentiate we want to start
at something else
okay and then say well what is its
primitive okay
now i don't have i don't have good
notation for anti-differentiation
so far and i don't want to introduce
this other stuff to do with integration
okay
so if i were to anti-differentiate this
right what's it going to turn into i'll
generally the most standard way to write
is to say well f is little right so what
it comes from something bigger
right so they use a capital okay now
it's not equal
right if this is the if i'm
anti-differentiating from this side to
this side the derivative is over here
does that make sense you see that so
capital f is our standard way of um
writing down what's up
ah okay yeah all right so now in some
ways i mean it's just
it's just letters right so we could make
it mean anything yeah
um and you know in the past when we talk
about polynomials we're like
capital p of x we do that all the time
we don't make it you know
lowercase p okay so in some ways it
doesn't matter however because it's such
a well recognized convention
like textbooks are going to use it exams
are going to use it
if you've been using capital so far i'm
gonna sort of encourage you to stop
doing that and try and distinguish
between
okay this is usually the derivative and
this is usually the proof okay is that
all right
okay so we started with an easy example
x squared and 2x
okay but let's try and start to
generalize this rule
right we know our general rule for
differentiating stuff with powers
right so if i've got x to the m yes um
what do i do what is the process of
differentiating
the power comes out the front first
right
and then i reduce the power by what
okay now if i were to go the other way
okay so i'm trying to find out if
if f of x were that
what is its primitive
okay so let's remember this again
the two steps you did were bring the
power out
and then reduce by one yes so if i want
to go in the opposite direction
i should do all those steps but i should
do them in exactly the opposite
way does that make sense okay so
instead of bringing the power out the
front and then reducing
okay remember you've got to do it
exactly backwards okay
so the first thing i'm going to do is
increase the power
okay now can you see why i'm increasing
the power first
it's because here i increase the power
last i'm trying to turn it upside down
exactly and you'll see why there'll be a
problem if you don't right
then here i multiply it so what should i
do now i should divide
okay now i'm almost done right
yeah this this is a whole family right
there's a whole bunch of different
functions that would satisfy
this so i'll chuck that constant on the
end
now let's just verify does it work does
it work
so um yeah i'll use red okay
so going back to um lower case is sort
of like
saying capital f but differentiate okay
it doesn't work let's do it log head
usually what do i do i
bring the power out the front
right and then i reduce the power by one
which will leave me with
n this denominator is still here
the constant becomes zero right sorry
that's a zero yes so it looks like it
checks out
that's fine okay so can you see if you
did it the other way
right if you divided first and then
increase the power
then this would work right in fact you'd
be off by a factor
okay all right so let's see if we can do
something damage
now here's the tricky thing because we
took a process that you're very familiar
with
right and then we just turned it on its
head we made everything backwards okay
um you will find particularly at the
beginning that you confuse these two
right you'll be like i'm meant to do
differentiate or meant to
integrate sorry anti-differentiate right
they're very similar to each other
so just watch out see i'm doing it too
um
let's have a column for the derivative
and a column for the primitive okay and
we'll do a whole bunch
okay so we already did an easy one
before
2x is going to turn into x squared plus
c
we already noticed that but can you see
how it works with this rule
okay um my power goes up
to 2 and then i divide by that power 2
which is what gets rid of the
coefficient
and that's why it's just on its own okay
well how about
multiplying it through by five what
difference will it make
okay well let me let's put the working
here even though i know you probably
could do it in your head
right but i'm going to put the power up
so 10
x squared and then i'm going to divide
through by the power
which leaves you with just 5 x squared
which makes sense
sorry plus c which makes sense because
this is 5 times bigger than that
so you'd expect this to be five times
bigger than this which it is
okay how about say
x square
push the power up and then
divide right
now
how about x to the power of uh
let's do let's do the square root of x
square root of x
now because we're trying to think in
terms of you know just like the
differentiation
if you saw this you're like i want to
put this in terms of something the power
of something
so this is x to the power of a half yes
x to the power of 3
let's do the let's do the steps okay
first thing is i'm going to
increase the power right so increase it
by one
makes it three on two yes now i take
that power and i divide through
so that's dividing by what's your
brackets there three on two
right plus your constant now dividing by
a fraction that's a bit gross
so let's put those numbers where they
belong
okay how about this
okay exactly the same you increase the
power by
one and then you divide by the new power
that props plus my constant okay
okay how about this one
why why why did it break my rule was
going so well
hold on a second hold on now stop stop
stop stop thinking
for a second right what are we trying to
do what are we trying to do
we're trying to go from a function this
is this is our derivative right and say
well where did it come from
what do you differentiate to get to that
what's the primitive wait wait is it
undefined because c can be any number
and because there's no accident it can
be
any number now what is this function now
i wrote it in a sneaky way i wrote it
just like these ways right
a normal way to write would be 10x right
well hold on hold on
what's the thing you differentiate and
you get to one on x
the natural log right
remember that one plus your constant of
course okay
because when you differentiate log x
your rule a different rule takes over
right sort of different it takes you to
one another
so we should update this a little bit
right
this rule was doing really well it was
really even working for weir numbers
like this okay
but it broke down here okay so what do i
need to say
over here this rule is not always true
what is it mr lo's looking for you but
yeah let me see
okay this thing here is not always true
you don't always simply increase the
number and then divide through
now there's a case where it stops
working what's the case
negative one what the power is now will
it work for all the negative powers
yes how could we how could we be sure
how about x to the minus three okay
let's go through the steps what do i do
first next to the minus two
increase the power and then divide
through by okay the minus i suppose i
should put that on the top
right plus my constant now how can i
know if i'm right or not
i differentiate right okay keep in mind
don't just this is one of the great
things about um this this topic okay
unlike say perms and columns okay you
can know when you're right or wrong here
because you get some result and you can
verify it immediately by differentiating
okay you can see all right what am i
going to have to do
this minus 2 is going to come out the
front and then i'm going to reduce the
power you do end up at x to the minus
three
it's fine so the only case where it
stops working
is where m is minus one because it's
it becomes something different entirely
okay so
then this is true where
n can't equal minus one
okay